so in this video I want to answer the
question is I am Oh syrup keto friendly
that stands for ISO multo illegal
saccharides another name for that would
be vitae fiber so in past cooking videos
Karen and I made certain types of keto
bombs or keto cookies using Vita fiber
and I was operating off of some
incomplete information thinking that it
wouldn't spike your blood Sugar's okay
now here's the concept when you consume
fiber which is a prebiotic you consume
it it bypasses the normal digestion in
the small intestine so in other words
your pancreas doesn't release any
enzymes that will break it down the
enzymes and the small intestine don't
break it down so you really don't have
anything there to break it down so it
passes through the small intestine and
then it gets into the large intestine
where your microbes now break it down
and they make some beneficial compounds
for you in exchange for feeding them
fiber which they use as their fuel so in
that way fiber doesn't increase your
blood sugars or insulin okay well
there's one study that shows in vitro
which means test tubes testing things
outside the body when they used IML
fiber it resists the pancreatic enzymes
in its digestion however when you
consume isomalt oh oligosaccharides it
breaks up in the stomach okay so as soon
as it hits the small intestine you're
getting another compound called isomalt
oohs this compound is almost completely
digested by the enzymes and the
intestinal border not by the pancreas
but by the enzymes in your small
intestine by 83 percent it has been
shown within 30 minutes to spiked your
blood glucose by 50 points and increase
your insulin by 5x also there was no
hydrogen gas noted upon testing no what
does that mean when you consume fiber
there is a gas released a hydrogen gas
which indicates that it is a fiber being
for
meant it okay when there's no hydrogen
gas that means there's no fermentation
going on so to make a long story short I
don't recommend buy the fiber anymore
and I will be deleting that video simply
because it will spike your blood sugars
because it does break down into this
which is affected by the enzymes
however there are other fibers and you
can use I put those in the description
thanks for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis how about that